cinco días después del inicio de las
votaciones para elegir un nuevo
presidente en italia la incertidumbre es
total los partidos políticos presentes
en el parlamento italiano no han logrado
encontrar un acuerdo durante la semana
la derecha ha presentado varios nombres
de candidatos que han sido rechazados
por la izquierda italiana y no ayudan
los enfrentamientos internos dentro de
los partidos divididos en corrientes
contrapuestas por el momento varias
hipótesis se manejan una sería la de
pedirle al actual presidente sergio
mataré la que prolongue su mandato otra
sería la de nombrar elegir a mario
draghi el actual jefe del gobierno pero
en este caso se tendría que encontrar un
nuevo primer ministro y otra opción
sería la que el centro-derecha escoja a
su propio candidato elija su candidato
sin el apoyo de la izquierda pero para
esto necesitaría lograr reunir los 505
votos necesarios para elegir un nuevo
presidente en el parlamento italiano